systems kim holds a honorary doctorate
from opsar university and an honorary
doctorate from ens
cashon he is a recipient of erc advanced
grant
with a project that is actually very
relevant to to today
on learning analysis and synthesis and
optimization of cyber physical systems
kim is also a member of the live longer
language of the royal
danish academy of science and letters
copenhagen
and the member of the danish academy of
technical science
and uh he has a lot of other
you know awards and uh i'm not going to
get into all because then i'm going to
take too much of his time so uh
kim it's now uh your floor nice to have
you
thank you thank you very much for the
nice words and the introduction and for
inviting me so uh
the short title instead of this census
is blah blah blah it's really i want to
sell you the newest version of your
statico so for many years i've been
working on newport now we are doing
synthesis
and we are combining symbolic methods
with
with machine learning and in fact it's a
little bit hard for me to see everything
on the screen uh
but i can see there is something called
willem fonten so i'm very happy to say
that i just got
a danish erc advanced look-alike grant
from denmark where in the next five
years we will consume many more
avenues along this line of research that
we're talking about here
so uh i've been this work that i'll be
presenting is in collaboration with a
great number of people
uh the top ones are from auburn
university
it's alexander david marius
and jacob tankfest they're really you
know the
the the heart the brains and and and and
and legs and arms behind behind
then there is manfred jaeger axel leger
and sean separates
and pranav ashok and maybe i should
point
also to young kaczynski young and prana
first from technical university of
munich
but also adrian de kont and max million
uh weiniger
has been you know contributing and and
there are some pointers to papers
uh and why is it i cannot get rid of
this uh
stupid line that is there i don't know
um i'll have to learn that i'm a teams
person not a zoom person so
so sorry yeah you have to move it all
the time it's a mess
can you move it can you can you can you
move it yeah like
i will not i will not touch it i think i
can remember
sorry for that anyway so i think the the
these people really have been working
very hard
in developing the tools in various
directions so
in my center we we work a lot with with
with companies
that come from embedded systems like a
physical system so you have
you really want to come up with control
programs that can say uh
here to the far right maybe you cannot
quite see what it is but it's a danish
pic
stable so you have pics in there you
want to automatically synthesize control
for the climate
the good climate that that should be in
those tables
home automation systems uh hearing aid
whatever autonomous vehicles
and of course we need we need models
where we can talk about
discrete phenomenas but timing of course
is important
consumption of resources stochasticity
that just peter just talked a lot about
but also all kinds of other continuous
phenomenas like
let's say the temperature in such a big
stable
so we want these controllers to be
obviously safe
they should do the correct thing but
they should also be optimal in the sense
that
maybe you avoid certain dangerous
situations but you're operating in
an optimal manner perhaps with respect
to some of these resources
and of course we would like to use
synthesis techniques to come up with
safe and optimal techniques and we've
been doing this since the last
last five years and even even
even even further back but the problem
is that you also would like to put those
strategies that you synthesize into
small little devices like a pacemaker
so how can we make these uh how can we
make these strategies that we synthesize
at compact in addition
so what i will do here is um there was a
duck stool
in october 2019 which
was about autonomous uh like there was a
very long time title
but there was a smart farming challenge
and i want to show you what the current
version of yupo statigo that we're about
to launch
can do for you on that on that smart
farming challenge
it's stuck still 19432 i'm sure you can
look it up there then i will i will say
a bit about the learning techniques the
better learning techniques that we are
that we are
now supporting uh
where we still have to really understand
the convergence properties of these
learning techniques so i will also say a
bit about approximations which is
you understand much better and some
words about how to get contacts
strategies and hopefully i will show
some applications
real life applications that we are
undertaking right now
uh so smart farming and yupos fatigue
i wouldn't have hoped that i could get
rid of this but i cannot
anyway uh so this is sort of a slightly
simplified version of the of the
challenge or or the benchmark
so you so the idea is that you have a
farm but you
want to rely entirely on on
autonomous robots to do the work for you
so you have various types of fields
here's just one field
so you can grow certain kinds of you
know crops there
may be wheat um and of course you have
to do all kinds of things maybe
fertilize whatever but you also have to
harvest
of course at the right point in time uh
the the field
and then uh at some you would then want
to bring the harvested
you know wheat into a collection point a
seal or whatever
so all these fields and these collection
points are connected by
roads various types and this is where of
course these robots will have to find
their way from
one interesting point to the other of
course we don't want to say exactly what
they want to do we want to give these
robots
absolute freedom to just move around
they should just be
made to we should just be able to
synthesize that they do the right thing
in a safe manner
so we optimize actually the outcome of
this
of this particular farm here so uh
i hope you know a bit about time
automata because this is actually now
the way that we will move
we will model the behavior the moving
behavior of a robot
so maybe you can just see the roads uh
these gray
shaded areas here these are the rope
this is the road and here you have the
silo and here you have the field
and then we simply we have some discrete
locations
where you can move back and forth from
so you see here this robot is currently
at the farm
can move to the ceiling or can make try
to make a move to the
to this point the gate c point here
and to make this um say more realistic
actually it takes some time to make such
a transition
uh from one location here to the next
location here
this is a so-called invariant that says
you can only be in these intermediate
locations for at most b time unit so i
said b to find here
so there's a little clock here that
makes sure that this is actually what's
happening
okay so uh and now i cannot see that but
i think
this is really annoying how do i move
this around
normally i click connect and try it now
now i cannot see the title but that's
okay
that's less important i move it away
okay okay very good
so what you can do so so so so we can
just do you pull model shaking so here's
a robot it can move around
i we have sort of a sort of ctel like
working logic so this is
saying is it possible to get this robot
number one into the field
and i also have a little a variable s
here that sort of in numbers
uh gives information about what what
segment are you in oh well that's green
so you can do that
no problem and now of course i cannot
move my tilde
maybe like this
okay so let's let me try to make it even
more realistic because in the time the
terminator you give
you give time bounce the best time the
shortest time well that's actually zero
or the worst time
it's actually b for all of these
transitions so you can actually work
with what's called stochastic time
ditometer
where these choices of time delays comes
with distributions
if you don't say anything else these
will be uniform distributions
so the time that it takes to make this
passing from one location to another
is governed by a uniform distribution
between 0 and b here
and now you cannot see my cursor
um and yeah so let's just
leave it like that so now you can
certainly because it's a completely
stochastic thing you have here
it's a macros market chain except that
it's an infinite state markup chain
but we have support of statistical model
checking so we can answer questions like
what's the probability
that within some time bomb 1000 that you
will have uh
these robots this robot being in the
field moving
you know randomly around according to
these distributions
so in 149 runs you will see that this is
essentially won this probability
now it could be that you have more than
one robot hopefully
many but let's just say two robots and
of course they are competing for
actually
you know moving around on the road we
want safety we don't want to have two
different robots
being in the same location at the same
time
so really as a controller what can i
control well i can control for instance
when i'm in the farm
whether this robot in the next move
should try to
go to the ceiling or should make an
attempt to go to the gate c here right
so now you want to find and this is
where we can
this is really a true you will satigle
feature
um i want to get rid of this little
additional
thing again here so this is a if you
just look at
the right hand piece here what this
property is saying it should always be
the case that
well actually if the rope that the
following is not the case
that the robot has is in a segment
greater than 1 and less than 14
that is it's actually on the roads and
the two robots is actually in the same
segment you don't you don't want this to
happen you want the safety property
to be satisfied and what you can do is
you can control you can synthesize
the most permissive strategy that will
ensure that
and you can name that in google sartico
you will take or actually take these
strategies with synthesizers first class
object
you can name them you can use them you
will see what we can use them for
a little bit later so
in fact you can simulate you can
simulate the behavior of these robots
figuring out what what segment are they
in while
if you do random simulation according to
this
particular synthesized safety strategy
you can model check whether uh you know
a particular property is true
under this strategy well yes or no for
these two questions
and of course we can also do statistical
model checking just as before
but now of the bit of the behavior of
these robots we're moving around
under that safety spine regime so of
course there can be non-determinism in
this safety strategy
it's it's most permissive so this
non-determinism that you have there when
we do statistical model checking is
result
so i would say again using uniform
distributions
we don't favor any particular behavior
over another one
of course that will be in the next thing
because we really would like to pick
the most optimal strategy to do the work
so let's try to extend now the scenario
you have the robots they can move around
we have a very small model of the of the
weather
here you can see uh it can it can be dry
or it can be wet there is a little
integer variable w that reflects that
and then there are what you actually see
here a rate of exponential
distribution so what i have here is a
model of the weather using a continuous
time markov chain
okay that's that's the thing you can
have in your sateego
then you can have other kinds of
continuous
phenomenons like the height of the wheat
this is f described by a differential
equation
the amount of corn you have in your and
your zero
that's uh the variable c
again uh described using a differential
equation
or the load that these two agents will
have at any given point in time
they can change because it might be that
you are harvesting
or you are unloading your load and
depending on what you are doing so these
harvesting and storing
a little boolean variables that will be
set at the appropriate moment
in time and will decide precisely what
is the differential equation you're
looking at
so you can see the wheat here there is
the maximum
the maximum height of the wheat so the
the
the wheat will grow proportionally to
the difference of the maximum height and
the current height
it will be encouraged by having a wet
absence of wetness
and if you're harvesting of course that
will contribute in a negative manner to
the
to the height of the of the of the
of the of the wheat let me not explain
the other differential equations but
you can actually write
arbitrary arbitrary differential
equations as you like
we can do simulation so here you can see
i'm looking out for the weather
uh so it's it's wet and dry and you can
see how the wheat
favors of course uh wet weather
here you see the entire the entire model
and here you actually see a simulation
of the
robots moving around yeah quite
arbitrarily
this is a random simulation what you can
see here is actually
you can see here i'm way into the
simulation
so you can see the height of the weed is
growing then apparently
it was it was being chopped down by
because there was a
robot coming by so on and so forth
and the the purple and the orange line
is the
uh it's a load of these two uh robots
and there's supposed to be another
little uh
plot here which is actually the amount
of corn that you have in the seal that
was very short
so now you saw a little demo of the
simulation features that we would like
to offer you
of them but i haven't talked anything
about strategies so far
so um let me just say what is the
workflow under your star table so we
have
these in this infinite state markup
decision process we have become
we have these continuous phenomenas uh
that will
you know that is described by
by differential equations uh of course
depending on
what this particular location of agents
so it's a it's an infinite state or as
we call it an euclidean markup decision
process
and that's really the optic where i want
to do my optimization
but before doing that what we will do is
that we will do an abstraction
and this was actually what i started by
showing you you will abstract
this euclidean markup decision process
into a time game so it's a two player
two player thing but now on a plate on
the timelaptometer
and this is precisely where we can
synthesize absolute safety strategies
most permissive safety strategies so
this is the sigma here
you already saw that i did that for the
movement of the of the robots we can do
model checking of this
safety strategy uh you also saw that but
what we can also do is that we can now
impose this safety strategy like a
shield i think
bloom talked about shielding so we did
this uh i would say even
even more years ago so you can use that
as a shield
that you add on top on the euclidean
market decision process
before you start doing doing what while
doing
learning doing reinforcement learning
where you try to optimize
want to find an optimal sub strategy
sigma zero here
that will optimize some expectation of a
cost or expectation of a game
so that's what you can do and then
hopefully you get
you can then use that optimized strategy
to analyze further
what is the behavior of your of your
infinite state markup decision process
under that learned
optimal sub strategy a soft strategy of
the safe of the safe strategy
so if i go back to my smart farming well
we saw this sex safe we already had that
and in our hands
uh and now we want to use that so this
is a bit of a mouthful
but what i really want to maximize is i
want to maximize
this continuous variable c that was the
amount of corn that you have in your
syllable
and for some time duration this little
red annotation here is
like information about that we
will want uh we actually allowed that to
take partial observability into account
so in a sense our strategy will only
depend on the loads
and the and the time so now i have my
optimal opt harvest strategy in my hand
and now i can examine that i can see
what
well what's the expectation of the of
this amount in the zero under
well let's start by looking at what is
to be expected if i just
follow the the most permissive safety
strategy and
this is the sort of arrows that you will
get in terms of the value of c
330 38 000 something
but now if you look at the same
expectations but now under this uh
learned
optimal sub strategy you will actually
get almost
threefold as much gain out of that
so that's uh that i think and you can
get some nice plots
in addition to that so um
what is the learning method that we are
that we are using so we actually
published that that
advert 2019 so you have this infinite
state
uh markup decision process in fact in
fact the states here are like
sets of some k-dimensional um
version of the of the rails so you have
c
f and uh and the loads and and whatever
so these are essentially the states uh
then you have some this
final set of discrete control actions
you can perform
and and then given
a concrete state and one of these
control actions what you get from your
transition functions is actually
the density of the successor state
right right and given that you take such
an action
that will take you to a certain target
state that actually also incurs
incurs a certain certain costs so
your next state density function and
cost functions
and the overall goal is actually to
reach some
designated set of
goals to be reached so everything i'm
saying here now will will assume that
you're
in that you stay within what you call
them
measurable uh braille measurable sets uh
for all the map maps to work out but
you can read about that in in this add
the paper
uh so what is it we want to find well we
want to find
a strategy maybe a mixed strategy where
for
any in one of those given states you
have
the a probability over these
controllable actions
so that's a strategy and now if for any
one
such strategy you can talk about the
expected cost of reaching the goal under
that strategy
and not obviously what we want to find
is we want to find the strategy sigma
star
that achieves the infimum
of this expectation overall strategies
uh so the way we do this is well we
we are using learning but we pretty much
like like also what use peterborough
stone we are
inspired by using partitioning so at any
given stage in this learning process
we will have a given partitioning a
finite partitioning
of of this infinite state space
so here i'm assuming that each of these
little boxes here corresponds to some
location
in our in our hybrid or or in the
atomizer that we are looking at
uh yeah so with this position the
partitioning there
you also comes also comes i would say an
abstraction of the transition function
so now given a partition a concrete
partition for instance
x here and a suggested target
partition say y here and an action say a
we will now have a lower and an upper
probability
of reaching of reaching from some state
in x
reaching the partition y so depending on
what concrete state you're in
and why the for each concrete state the
next
doing a there will be a given
probability of reaching y
and now raging over all the states in x
that will give you an infimum and
supremum
and that will give you the interval and
in a similar manner
there will be an abstraction of the cost
function which is now
uh when you lift it to the partitions
will be an interval
an infinite cost and a supremum cost
so really what we have at hand here is a
two and a half player game
because of course i want to find i want
to choose these controllable actions a
and b
so that i minimize the the overall
expectation of reaching the goal
but there is another player which is
actually the guy that chooses
the concrete states in these partitions
and they cannot either play with me
in the in in towards minimizing these
expectations
or against me so you have to have these
minimum and maximum
versions of this expectation of reaching
the goal and what you can actually show
and this is what we do in the aqua paper
but also in the recent isoler
2020 paper that we never even got a
chance to present
so this is horrible is that we show that
under
all these measurability assumptions that
the true informal
of the infinite state markup decision
process
value lies pre allies
lies for sure within um
the the expectation you get are under
this
of the the minimum version and the mag
and and the expectation of
the maximum version for any state right
and here this
here this is the the equivalence class
in which this
state is lying so that's very nice
and actually by by refining
more and more and more these
partitionings if you do that
to an arbitrary precision degree you
will actually in the limit
hit they will converge from either side
to this uh
to this true value of the infinite state
markov decision process
so how do we do the learning and now i
have to move this around a little bit
again thank you very much
for the advice here so so this so the
learning is actually simulation based so
we keep track
for each location and partitioning we
keep track
of two values for each action what is
the true value
of that location for this partition x
given a and given b
so these are non-negative rails we also
keep track of how many how frequently
have been in seeing
such a location and partition so that's
a true learning version there's also an
in-learning version
so what do we do repeatedly will we
generate a random run
uh so we and a concrete run so we are in
some concrete state and we use these
weights here
um of the two values of the partition
that this concrete state is in
to choose randomly between these
controllable actions
and of course we also have the model at
our hand so we can use
the stochasticity there to actually
pinpoint precisely
randomly that is the next concrete state
so we simply generate one such concrete
run
uh yeah and they all told me
i don't know whether it's my
i don't know yeah so what do we do when
we have this concrete run of course we
update all the statistics uh of how much
we have been visiting and then we
backward propagate
we backwards update these two values
in this in this manner here and of
course we keep on doing that but then
what we also do is that we keep an eye
on a
a possible sub partitioning of the
partition we are looking at
to see if that sub partition if the
parts of that sub condition
differs significantly because if that's
the case then we throw in
that soft partitioning and we start all
over again
so that's essentially what what we're
doing in your statigo
so here just just to see what can come
out of that here is a very very small
um euclidean mdp so you have this
one by one you know
two-dimensional space here so you have a
point here and then there are two
actions you can either
try to make a move along this this
diagonal up here
uh that will with some uniform
distribution
get take you to anywhere in the in the
yellow square or you can do
this more horizontal move that will
with the uniform distribution take you
to some random point in the blue in the
blue square here and you really would
like to get to this
nice green bar here without before
hitting the the red danger zone here
and here you can see the strategy that
stratego
learned after some number of iterations
so
up here it's very safe you can just go
for the fast
fast safe safe move and down here it's
better to
to go for the for the slow move here
actually i forgot to say that the slow
move is not all bad because it's quite
cheap
so so that's that's good whereas the
fast move is quite costly
but this is the cost optimal strategy
that drupal strategy
learned and here you can see the lower
and upper bound corresponds
but of course we could also just have
used heavy duty
mathematica and we tried to do that and
simply partitioning things and spend a
lot of hours
uh trying to with finer and finer
partitioning trying to compute lower and
upper bound
uh expected cost and corresponding
strategies
and then this is what this is what you
will see um
from yeah from that and we know of
course that these will converge
we can also take we can actually also
re-examine these
strategies that we learn and actually
explicitly compute
using numerical analysis what are the
expected costs
that will that the best expect is lower
and upper bound cost that
we could obtain from i would say either
either the course partitioning here with
few learning steps or
or the more refined partitioning here
over here and what you can see is
actually that the learned expected cost
is not
always um strictly within the lower and
upper bound and why is that well because
we only spend
some amount of effort in doing the
learning so uh
sometimes in a petition we did learn the
optimal move in that particular thing
but of course what we really would like
to prove is and this is still a
challenge for us
is to prove uh the convergence of this
learning method for euclidean
mdps uh i will skip this uh
thing with the with the compactness just
to say
that uh as we speak we are
using yupo stratego to control traffic
lights in denmark we made even a company
so this is one traffic light in all
block
near me so of course that's very
important
it's the exact same traffic and this is
the the old uh
controller and you can see cars are
stacking up and here you see
the smooth tubeless sativo control
thingy we also are using your santiago
to control
uh in a safe manner uh what's called the
yeah basins or water management for
urban water
in a safe manner yeah let me stop here i
spent my
quite well my time thank you very much
thank you very much give a wonderful
talk i mean your applications are
amazing
exactly
any any question from the audience
so i i have a question if
i take advantage of the fact that uh
nobody uh knows himself
so um you when you design these
strategies you assume that
the automata are given yes so what what
you synthesize is
essentially the actions on on the
automotive right so you're not
looking at synthesizing uh structure so
the structure is given and you just
synthesize the well
well we also applied this to railways to
railway
i mean think not on farming but
controlling trains on
on on train stations so there the idea
is that you would you would
and also in this water in this water
thing here we will
have we will generate this model of
mobility
so to speak direct from images so if we
have if you if you give me a
blueprint of a a railway network in a
station
and railway station or some some some
satellite pictures over
here you see a particular it's not a
lake it's a pond
then then you can since then you can
construct these uh
i would say a large part of the models
directly
yeah yeah no so in fact you know i was
just trying to understand how this
relates to
deep frame i mean to policy gradients in
reinforcement learning so
there you have an idea but our learning
method
is reinforcement learning so we are i
know i know yeah
but i was wondering whether you could
use policy gradients you know i mean
you're you're doing some kind of
partition refinement
you know in your learning you know yeah
yeah maybe maybe maybe in the partition
one could be smarter but here we are we
are simulation based
i mean this is an infinite state space
right so we
so i really think uh and this this
simulation based
reinforcement learning that we are using
actually com
works very very very fast so um yeah
yeah
no but i mean this policy gradients are
similar i mean you
you you essentially sample a uh you know
an execution
i mean you you do a simulation and based
on that simulation then you
you try to to find your you know you
you try to to to find the gradient you
know
so that's why it's called for its
gradient so you go
in the the direction
the gradient direction the most uh
reward in
your case would minimize the that you
would have you know
anyway it's just an idea maybe you can
you can play with that too you know
so i mean for us the challenge is the
following but it's very nice i mean
it's yeah the first the chance is like
the last point
i mean we want this to operate online so
when we control traffic lights it's not
that we spend one year
and then we synthesize the strategy it's
being computed online
like in a reciting horizon manner so to
keep up with the speed is very important
we also would like that to to learn
strategy profiles for multiplayer
systems so maybe these
the robots are really having their
different objectives maybe
maybe it's not the same objective
they're working towards so
so we are we are very interested in
trying to extend these learning
techniques we have to to learn
strategy profiles yeah maybe maybe near
peterman that i think is just listening
in
could give some advice there
all right so uh let's let's close it
here very
very nice very interesting talk uh so we
are now
going to take a short break until i mean
we are 15 minutes late i hope that's not
going to be too much of a problem so
let's let's reconvene at uh
uh in at 45 now uh so in
seven minutes and yeah
all right thanks guys very nice
kim can you hear me yeah this is this is
alessandro
hello um what is the relationship
between
the euclidean mdps and uh
you know panel gardens lmps or general
stochastic hybrid models
pen and gardens i think these are much
more specific we are working on
arcade right i mean pan and garden is
working
at a more general level i would say
i mean uh he works over more
unmeasurable
[Music]
sets right um sort of
over polish spaces right so in the end
yeah well maybe this is beyond my my
my knowledge i mean he doesn't know but
i mean i think it's i think it's very
close
also to the sort of general stochastic
resistance models
that i'll be talking about yeah
absolutely absolutely there are many
many similarities and
yeah yeah very good
yeah and it's in discrete time
still no no time has continued well
yeah because time is like a part of the
the time
is one of the dimensions that you can
have yeah okay but the actions are
discrete
right yeah yeah okay
yeah so that's good